[Music]
hey you guys welcome to my tomes of
terror show this is my little book
review situation that i have going on
that i put up every monday
so on this installment we're gonna be
doing another book by
jack ketchum
now i've done at least one of his before
maybe two i can't remember i know i did
the girl next door for sure which if you
haven't read jack ketchum's the girl
next door
that is one of the most soul-crushing
books you will ever read and it's based
on a true story um i don't remember if
i've done any more because i have
several of his books uh so if i haven't
done another one other than the girl
next door then i will eventually get
around because i'm pretty sure i have
off season and i have a couple other
ones too so i cuz i really really like
jack ketchum but this book right here
is one that this came out back in 1995
and i remember seeing it in the
bookstore because in the late 1990s i
was actually buying a bunch of kind of
leisure paperbacks
and they usually had kind of a lot of
you know what used to be called
splatterpunk type stuff or kind of more
extreme horror you had you know jack
ketchum you had richard layman you had
douglas clegg edward lee people like
that so i was buying a lot of those
around this time
and i actually remember i'm pretty sure
i remember being in barnes and noble
probably like sometime in the late 90s
early 2000s and picking this book up and
not buying it because i thought it would
be too much of a bummer
because of what it was about because
animals you guys
but
uh so i never did read it i read most of
jack
jack ketchum's other stuff but i never
did get around to reading this one but
then i noticed that it was on you know
recently i noticed it was on kindle
unlimited so i was like what the hell
i'll pull the trigger on that and see if
it's really good because it has like
really really excellent reviews and i
have to say that this was
pretty amazing it is a bummer like you
know it's the jack ketchum we're talking
about like all his stuff is
is kind of a bummer because i mean the
dude writes it
i think the way that he writes um you
know his style is just so kind of like
matter-of-fact and not you know there's
no kind of like frills or anything on it
no bells and whistles
and
he just like everything you know this
the shittiest stuff happens and then it
just gets shittier and shittier and
shittier and you're just kind of like
hoping that you know you'll get to the
end it's like will there be a light at
the end of the tunnel where will there
be some good out of this uh not usually
um so
like bad shit's gonna happen this book
actually does have
a sort of happy-ish ending i will say
that
but
generally like some really really
terrible [ __ ] happens in this now i will
say this book as i said came out in 1995
and if you get the paperback and if you
get the ebook which is the one that i
read this also um has another novella uh
appended to the end of it which is
called the passenger so i'm gonna talk
about that too um that's like it was
like a hundred hundred twenty pages
something like that uh at the end so
it's almost kind of like it's almost
kind of like two books in one to be
honest with you and the passenger is
like way nastier uh than red was
but you know i'll get into that in a
minute so
jack ketchum if you don't know he uh
unfortunately passed away a couple of
years ago
in
2018 that actually wasn't his real name
it was a pen name uh his real name was
actually dallas mayer i believe uh but
yeah so sadly he passed away but uh if
you haven't ever read any jack ketchum
uh you really should because he's
something else he's actually one of my
favorite horror writers and uh the girl
next door probably the one to start with
unless
you know you
you want to like maintain your faith in
humanity then probably don't read it but
you know that's probably one to start
with but all of his [ __ ] is great like
pretty much every book that i've read of
his is great and this one is great too
and i'm actually really sorry that i
didn't read it back in the day because
i guess i thought
when i read the back when you know the
the description on the back i was just
kind of like well i don't know if i want
to write if i want to read something
that's that because even back then i was
kind of like sensitive about
um you know bad stuff happening to
animals and i don't give it like i said
i don't give a [ __ ] what you do to
people in horror movies or horror books
or anything just yeah [ __ ] them all up
and it doesn't usually bother me all
that much but the second something
happens to like a kitty or a doggy or
something i'm just kind of like nope as
you know i don't want to read about that
but so i will say that if you're very
sensitive to
[ __ ] up [ __ ] happening to animals then
maybe give this one a pass because
it's a pretty [ __ ] up [ __ ] happens to
animal in it so i'm just gonna say
so the story of red
is about this guy his name is avery and
he lives in this small town he's kind of
like an older guy he's like in his 60s
and he is a widower uh and he has kind
of like you know just a very quiet life
he runs like a general store in this
little town and he just has his house
and he just kind of like i said he's a
widow where his wife died and he's just
been kind of living by himself it's just
him and his dog red and they just kind
of go fishing and hang out at the thing
and everyone in the town kind of knows
him and he's just like he's just like a
really likable older dude you know just
living out the rest of his days in peace
and quiet
so him and red are out fishing one day
and uh you know he's caught a couple
fish having a good day it's it's all
nice and quiet and then all of a sudden
these three [ __ ] snot-nosed teenagers
uh turn up and
and this is like really the first few
pages of the of the book and you know i
mean this scene is just like so tense
because you really know like something
bad's gonna happen and you're just kind
of like waiting for it like your stomach
it's just kind of like coiled because
you know this is gonna go bad even
though the kids i mean they walk up with
like a rifle and they say yeah they've
been out like hunting or shooting in the
woods or whatever and at first they seem
kind of like friendly but avery is
really wary of them because he's kind of
like yeah i don't like the way this is
[ __ ] going like they seem to have a
little bit of an attitude
so as it goes on they're kind of like
asking them questions about always fish
and about all this other stuff and then
they start uh with what they really came
for which is they just want to like rob
him
so
he's like look he knows who the kids are
uh you know because like i said this is
kind of a small town and these are kind
of like the town rich kids pretty much
so you know and they're just kind of out
there [ __ ] around i guess they're
supposed to be like maybe 16 17
something like that they're like high
school students
so he's like look i don't want any
trouble um you know i got a wallet it's
in my truck you know it's there's maybe
20 bucks in it just take it it's fine
you know just
you know he doesn't want any trouble
like i said
so the kids are just kind of like oh
well that's not really enough blah blah
and then uh i hate to tell you
but just for shits and giggles
these kids just straight up blow off the
dog's head
uh just because they can and because
they think it's funny so one of them
does it and then like the other
teenagers like one of them kind of looks
like oh man that was [ __ ] up but then
the other one just they're just like
laughing about it
so his beloved dog red who he's had for
a very long time who i believe his wife
gave to him much like in
you know what i mean in john wick uh
fashion uh his wife gave him the dog
so he's had this dog for a really long
time and uh was his companion and these
just brats just came along and just blew
the dog's head off for like for no
reason at all because like i said they
didn't even need the money or anything
like that
so from there
uh follows
as i said you're gonna get like john
wick vibes although this came out like a
long time before that but it's not
really like that it's a much quieter
story because honestly at first all
avery wants he doesn't want money he
doesn't want
revenge he doesn't want to like turn the
kids inside out or anything like that
which makes him a better man than me
because that's what i would do
but at first all he wants is he just
wants them to take responsibility he
wants them to be sorry and he wants to
go so the first thing he does is he
tries to do the right thing and he goes
to um
the cops and then he or actually he goes
to the the kids uh the kid that shot his
uh dog it was him and his brother and
then their friend
so he goes to that to the kid's dad and
it's basically like hey you know this is
[ __ ] up um you know your kids came
across me i was fishing they tried to
rob me and then they blew my dog's head
off and you know i really liked that dog
and uh you know so i would really
appreciate it if they would take
responsibility for that you know if they
would just say they were sorry
and you know if they would learn that
that was a [ __ ] up thing to do so
that's all he's asking for
now the kid's dad is one of these kind
of he's like a real estate developer
dude and he's kind of like this
kind of stereotypical like rich [ __ ]
where
uh he kind of started out as a redneck
but he made it good so now he has all
this money and he's one of the
wealthiest people in town and he owns
all this [ __ ] and so he's basically like
my kids would never do that you know
piss off yo stupid old man what do you
want money here i'll give you some money
and he's like look i don't want your
money i just want your kids to like
acknowledge that what they did was
[ __ ] up and you know wanted them to
apologize but of course they won't uh
the kids just [ __ ] deny it we weren't
even there blah blah
so at this point as i said i the one
thing i like about this story is that
avery is like such a nice man and he's
just like a really good character he's
just like a regular older guy he was
just like living his life and then these
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] came and did
this and he doesn't even try to like
like i said he doesn't try to punch him
out or nothing like that he tries to go
the right way he goes to their dad and
that doesn't work out and then he goes
to the police and he's like i know that
nothing's gonna come of this and
everything but i just want you guys to
know that this happened and he's like i
don't really
he's like i don't really want anything i
just want them to you know
face some consequences for what they did
he's like i know that blowing a dog's
head off you know especially back then
in 1995 it's like it's not really gonna
really net you that much jail time i
guess and like i said it was just his
word against theirs they're denying that
it happened
so as the story goes on
and he really is not getting any
satisfaction he ends up going to well he
doesn't do this but the media or
actually this woman that's like a
reporter uh she actually who's local she
actually gets um
interested in the story and she's like
man this is [ __ ] up i really want to
cover this so she goes to him and
convinces him to go to the media to get
maybe something to happen on it uh at
which point uh you will not be surprised
to learn that the rich [ __ ] and the
kids and the friend
uh
you know they pretty much amp up the
[ __ ] so it gets to a point where
it's like a [ __ ]
blood feud and like i said avery
really only does bad [ __ ] when he gets
pushed into it i mean the rich [ __ ]
like burn down his store although he
can't prove it and it's like so they
start like
essentially like maintaining like terror
against him because of him trying to get
like i said all he wanted was a [ __ ]
apology for killing his goddamn dog and
they won't even give him that they won't
even admit that they did it they
wouldn't even admit that it was [ __ ]
up and it's just kind of like so it just
keeps escalating and escalating and
escalating um until it's just this
horrific
situation that this poor old man got uh
brought into so that's essentially the
whole entire story it's like a revenge
story but it's as i said it's kind of
like a much quieter one and it takes
like a long time
for
[ __ ] to like build up but it just builds
up just ratchets up very very slowly
everything just gets worse and worse and
worse and worse and uh i'm not gonna
spoil how it ends because i really do
think people should read this but uh it
i will say that it does have like a
somewhat happy ending at least compared
to like a lot of other jack ketchum
stuff that i've read so there is that
but as i said this is a pretty
it's pretty messed up um and if you
really do not like uh anything in
stories that has anything to do with uh
you know [ __ ] up [ __ ] happening to
animals then this is really gonna bother
you and it happens like almost
immediately uh at the beginning of the
story because it's kind of the inciting
incident so i mean it bothered me uh
thinking about it and um but i read the
story anyway it's actually like a great
uh story because and avery is just such
a great character because he's just as i
said he's just kind of this quiet older
dude and he gets put into this situation
and he didn't want to be in that
situation but all he wants is for
someone to acknowledge that what what
happened was wrong and that you know why
won't anybody take responsibility for it
and that's all he wants and he can't
even get that so you know all of this
horrible death and destruction kind of
stems out of that so it's actually a
really good
like character study of him
and also how just a regular nice person
can get put into these extraordinary
circumstances and you know what kind of
stems out of that so it's actually like
an excellent excellent story so as i
said at the end of the book if you i
believe you get the print book for sure
if you get the e-book because that's
what i read
there's also another novella at the end
which is called the passenger which i'm
assuming was written right around the
same time
and this one this is also very good much
nastier
this is about a woman named janet morris
who is a defense attorney and she has
been um defending this guy who
apparently like shot a family or
something like that that's not kind of
the main part of the story although it
does kind of tie in later on but
what ends up happening is that she is uh
on her way home or something like that
one night and her car breaks down
and she ends up getting picked up by
this young woman
and uh when she gets in the car she
realizes this young woman that she went
to high school with her
and so she's like oh my god i haven't
seen you in such a long time but they
weren't really friends because they were
in different social circles and that
kind of makes a big uh
there is kind of like a an element of
class in both of these stories now that
i think about it because janet was kind
of like a more cheerleader wealthier you
know upper class type girl and like i
said now she's a defense attorney so
she's kind of wealthier uh whereas this
other girl this other woman whose name
is marion was more like a white trash
type of thing and it's like she's
kind of stayed in the same small town
and is
turns out um is kind of crazy
actually a lot crazy um yeah so as it
goes on uh there's this kind of there's
all of these so there's like three
different tendrils you have like janet
story and her and her boyfriend who is
uh you know trying to like he's cheating
on her but there's all this other kind
of stuff going on with that then there's
this thing with her and marian and then
they meet up with these three dudes that
are like criminals
and
it goes uh again this is one that is
like really really [ __ ] up like some
really [ __ ] up happens as [ __ ] up
stuff happens and i'm talking about
trigger warning for like child for like
children being shot uh all kind of like
terrible [ __ ] happens over the course of
this one night and it's almost kind of
like
because janet got a ride with this woman
who which you think would be safe and
she's like oh hey you know i kind of
remember you from high school and you'd
think that that would be fine
things are totally not fine um you know
what i mean and uh so yeah and you just
will not believe like the crazy [ __ ]
[ __ ] that happens in this and i kind of
feel like toward the end
and like i said i don't really want to
spoil this because this is actually a
really good story too but it's like
toward the end it gets a little i don't
know if i'd say it's like unbelievable
but it does kind of like strain
credulity a little bit but maybe not i
don't know maybe there's like crazier
[ __ ] going on out there than than i
think but it does kind of go in like
some really
i don't even know how i want this but
well it's just kind of like as it goes
on when they meet up with these three
killers
who end up like killing a cop and then
there's all this other kind of [ __ ] and
then they're like on the run and they
have to keep stealing cars and you know
they're just rape and murder and it's
just so the worst possible [ __ ] happens
in this like i said rape murder the
whole entire family is being shot and
then it just gets worse and worse and
then when it gets to the end where this
where this place is where this final
confrontation is there's just all kind
like the worst [ __ ] you can imagine is
going on at this place
um not supernatural it's not
supernatural in any way it's all
like criminals but it's just like terror
like human trafficking just whatever the
worst [ __ ] you can imagine is going on
in this story so there's that as well so
if you have not read any jack catch them
like i said this actually would probably
be a good one to start with and pretty
much any one of them would be good to
start with um but
no going in he is known as a more like
quote unquote extreme writer so his
stuff is very
nasty um you know terrible terrible
things happen to people in these
terrible things happen to animals so
that's going to bother you and like i
said there's there's rape there's just
all kind of like terrible things going
on uh it's not
it's interesting because i think i
brought this up before when i was
talking about richard layman who is you
i mean usually those kind of guys are
grouped together
richard layman's stuff to me seems a
little more like all of the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] and his is more meant to be
titillating
jack ketchum's not so much i i never
really get the sense that he's writing
it i mean all the [ __ ] that happens in
there is like really depraved but i
never get the sense and i guess it's
just his writing style i never get the
sense that he's
enjoying it or getting off it he's just
showing it to you you know i mean it's
just very matter of fact he's like this
is some [ __ ] up [ __ ] that happens in
the world in real life because as i said
i don't i don't actually remember he
might have done some supernatural [ __ ]
but you his you know kind of wheelhouse
was more
real [ __ ] you know realistic [ __ ] going
on
criminals and things like that um he was
more interested in human monsters than
supernatural monsters i can't remember
offhand if he'd written any supernatural
stuff or not most of his stuff was human
monsters uh you know particularly like i
said the girl next door and uh so that
was kind of like what he was fascinated
about but as i said you never get the
sense that he's
writing about that like
you know to to make you like get off on
it or enjoy it anyway it's always like
kind of unpleasant
um the way he puts it across but it's
still like really compelling to read if
that makes any sense so yeah so as i
said this this uh
novel read the one about the dog uh was
actually made into a movie which i
didn't know in 2008 i think tom sizemore
was in it i don't know if the movie was
any good um i probably wouldn't watch it
because reading about a dog getting its
head blown off is bad enough i certainly
do not want to see it um but i kind of
want to see it because i'm curious
because the book is really good but
i don't know let's maybe i'll get around
to it but they did make a movie out of
it uh they made a movie about a couple
of his other ones too girl next door i
think they made into a movie twice uh
to be honest with you and i think one of
his other ones maybe off season was made
into a movie too but uh yeah not not a
lot of his stuff was unfortunately
but this one uh was so if you want to
see the movie check it out but i'm sure
the book is better uh but yeah so
that'll do it for this tomes of terror i
will see you guys on the next one
bye